hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear going back once again to my
favorite decade for horror probably the
1970s for this one
so bob clark uh he was a very
interesting filmmaker now he was born in
the united states i think he was born uh
new orleans actually uh but he did most
of his most iconic work in canada
and i think what's most interesting
thing about him is that his directorial
resume i guess is just kind of like all
over the map i mean he made
some real like cult classics like black
christmas obviously children shouldn't
play with dead things he made like a
bunch of beloved kind of 80s comedies
like porkys and a christmas story and
also in the late 90s and early 2000s he
also made some maybe less than
celebrated like family movies like the
baby geniuses movies and [ __ ] like that
uh so you know just just kind of like
all over the place like i said uh sadly
and i actually didn't know this until i
was like researching him a little bit
for this show
he was actually him and his son were
both killed by a drunk driver back in
2007 and in 2007 when he was killed they
were also they were actually talking
about doing a remake of children
shouldn't play with dead things and the
movie that we're talking about today
which is called death dream so in his
early days uh clark worked a lot with uh
the actor director screenwriter makeup
artist alan ormsby
who uh wrote and starred in the
aforementioned children shouldn't play
with dead things he also penned the
screenplay for another movie that we
talked about on the show uh the very
underrated ed gein based horror film
deranged which came out in 1974. clark
didn't direct that although he did
produce it and alan ormsby did write the
screenplay for it so after kind of the
cult success i guess of children
shouldn't play with dead things which
came out in 1972
but a little bit before the kind of i
don't know if it was like necessarily a
mainstream breakout but it was certainly
like more well-received like critically
and as well as with audiences of black
christmas which like i said very very
early slasher uh halloween was
super indebted to black christmas but
before right before that uh bob clark
and alan ormsby teamed up on a this
creepy little anti-vietnam horror film
loosely inspired by the famous 1904
short story the monkey's paw by ww
jacobs
so the film uh which was also released
in 1974 a little bit before black
christmas i think is today better known
as death dream
though prince of it still bear the
original title which was dead of night i
assumed that the title was eventually
changed to avoid confusion with the very
well-known british anthology film dead
of night from 1945 and it was also a
british tv series called that uh in 1972
so i'm assuming they thought that it'd
be too confusing so they changed it to
death dream
now deathstream in my opinion is a very
very undervalued
1970s gem
uh it is a very unsettling
psychological but also supernatural
reflection on
how the horrors of war can like change a
person
and it also has this a really really
devastating like heartbreaking ending
which actually was like really bleak uh
and i actually because it's bleak but i
kind of dug it the film actually
features one of only a handful of film
appearances by the actor richard backus
he would actually later go on to get a
bunch of emmy nominations for his
television work in the 1980s he was an
actor on some soap operas and he did a
lot of screenwriting and stuff as well
it also has some very early special
effects by tom savini so you know
there's that alan ormsby's wife uh
anya's also in this movie and also in
this movie is john marley who was in
love story and it was in the godfather
he was the guy who the you know the
horse head was found in his bed so
there's that and uh lynn carlin is in
this too she actually got an oscar
nomination in 1968 for the john
cassavetes film faces john marley was in
that too by the way
uh death stream was also shot in my home
state uh of florida shot in a town
called brooksville which is about 45
miles from tampa i've never been there
although i did live in tampa for a
little while so at the beginning of the
movie we see a soldier in vietnam who we
later find out his name is andy brooks
now he gets shot by a sniper right after
witnessing the death of his friend and
fellow soldier who was also shot by the
same sniper like he's standing there
going oh [ __ ] and then he gets shot too
so it appears that andy is hit right
through the heart so it's pretty clear
that he was killed outright but then we
hear this very eerie like woman's
voiceover uh telling andy that he has to
come back because he promised he would
so the story then cuts to the rest of
the brooks family and they're all
sitting at the dinner table so the mom
is christine the dad is charles and he
has a sister who's like she looks like
she's been 19 or 20 or something like
that maybe a little bit older named
kathy
so it's established pretty definitively
right away that dad and kathy are
worried uh because they haven't heard
from andy for a couple of months
and at this point they're starting to
fear the worst they think something bad
has happened
mom though is kind of just prattling
happily along oh everyone's asking about
andy he'll write soon and we can't wait
to see him when he gets home and we'll
have everybody will come over and see
him and blah blah
so charles and kathy are just kind of
like glancing at each other with kind of
these uh-oh mom's delusional kind of
expressions
but really neither one of them have the
heart to burst her bubble and be like
hey it's been a long time probably
something bad has happened so they just
kind of like politely very desperately
try to change the subject away from
talking about andy but she's you know
nothing doing she just keeps on going on
about it now in the middle of dinner
there's a knock at the door and it turns
out that the very thing that charles and
cindy were dreading all along has come
to pass the visitor is a uniform guy
from the army he hands the family a
telegram telling them that andy was
killed in action as we saw at the
beginning of the film
now both charles and cindy like accept
this right away and are just immediately
grief stricken but christine is not
having it and she just starts screaming
the whole it's a lie it's a lie you know
that's it's not right
and then she just like runs up to
upstairs
and later that evening charles actually
finds her sitting in the dark in i think
andy's room and she's seemingly talking
to andy while she's staring at a candle
she's like sitting in his rocking chair
and like staring at the candle and it's
almost kind of like you know you
promised you'd come back it's that kind
of thing it's almost like she's doing
like some kind of low-key incantation or
some [ __ ] like that now even later that
same night cindy hears a noise
downstairs and wakes her parents up now
after a brief like a little bit of a
scare it's not it's actually not a cat
scare it's a little dog scare this time
which you know that's a that's an
original take but yeah so they do that
and they don't see anybody at first but
then they notice that the front door is
like wide open
and then when they investigate further
they find andy standing in the front
room in full uniform looking fit as a
fiddle obviously they're overjoyed they
run over they start hugging oh my god oh
my god it's like you're here you're here
i mean then they start figuring as you
would probably if this happened in real
life
that the army must oh they must have
made some kind of clerical error and you
know send us their early telegram
telling you we're dead but obviously
that was wrong it was a mistaken
identity or something like that so
they're super super happy as like i said
you would be
so the family all sit down at the table
together and uh from the jump though
it's pretty evident that andy ain't the
same
uh he doesn't really talk all that much
uh he won't eat or drink anything he
just looks generally kind of
spacey and also kind of like menacing
like he's just sitting there like
staring
blank-faced like into the middle
distance like thousand-yard stare kind
of thing
but the rest of the family are kind of
like too happy to see him and they're
too busy like firing questions at him to
really notice like he that he's really
off
when charles tells his son that he's
kind of laughing about it he's like you
know the craziest thing the army had
actually told him like they came they
gave us a telegram like earlier and told
us that you died
and then andy just gives this really
really creepy like really chilling smile
and says i did
and they're like then there's his long
pause and then everybody starts to laugh
but it's this really awkward like
disquieting type of laughing
and this scene is so great because bob
clark's direction here i mean it makes
this scene like doubly doubly creepy
because they just he just focuses a
little bit too closely on like the
characters like open laughing mouths and
like their teeth and stuff so it kind of
makes
it kind of makes them all look like
terror riches or kind of like you know
like fear monkeys or something like that
because you know how like when monkeys
like they get mad and they do the teeth
display so it kind of looks a little bit
like that but not like overtly but just
enough to be like it you know what i
mean it's kind of like that and he also
kind of like allows this very very
painful forced laughter about this joke
uh to go on for way longer than is
entirely comfortable so yeah that's like
a really really effective scene i really
like that creeps me the [ __ ] out so as
the days goes on charles in particular
the dad he becomes convinced that
something is seriously wrong with his
son
now cindy the sister she kind of
suspects something as well but she's
still kind of holding out hope that
he'll snap out of whatever this
thing is this phase is that he's in
christine though the mom is in complete
and utter denial she insists andy has
been through a horrible ordeal in
vietnam which is true uh they can't
expect him to just come back home and
get back to normal right away also true
um you know they're gonna have to give
him some time like i said this sounds
reasonable you know but andy the way
andy's acting seems to go way beyond any
kind of like oh he needs some time for
like a minor readjustment type of thing
you know what i mean the guy barely
talks uh he spends his like entire days
just sitting in his rocking chair
staring straight ahead at nothing and
spends his nights like not telling
anybody where he's going but he's
basically just wandering around in the
nearby graveyard and getting up to some
other shenanigans now not only that as
if that wasn't bad enough
before he even arrived back at his
family's home
he had actually killed the truck driver
who gave him a ride because he was
hitchhiking to get back home now no one
begins to suspect his involvement in
this murder until later but we as the
audience saw it happen uh so we know
something is
horribly horribly devastatingly wrong
with andy before his family does which
actually really causes some very
effective suspense there's also kind of
a great thing where the various family
members reactions to andy's behavior
start causing like a huge amount of
turmoil in the household um especially
between charles and christine like
husband and wife and they start having
these blistering arguments which
sometimes kind of get physical like he
kind of like slaps her around a little
bit and it's just kind of like yeah it's
a it's a bad bad situation and then
later on in not gonna lie probably the
film's most horrifying scene i found its
most horrifying scene uh a bunch of
neighbor kids kind of come over that i
guess andy used to kind of like hang out
with or you know show them how to do
stuff like when before he went and they
come over and they're like hey like
check out my karate moves and you know
want to play football with us and all
this other kind of stuff and he actually
smacks around like one of the kids and
then he picks up his family's dog whose
name is butch
and just like strangles it like with one
hand like that and it just goes on for
such a long time and it's just awful
it's awful um and like the horrified
kids are just like watching the whole
time going what the [ __ ] and it's just
like awful this sequence not i'm not
gonna lie right here like i said you
know how much i love animals this
weekend is very very very upsetting um
so if you don't like to see even fake i
mean obviously it's fake but if you
don't even like to see fake harm done to
animals and movies you might want to
skip it kind of wish i had because like
i said it goes on a very long time and
even though it's not super graphic just
the way that it's shot and the way it's
just like really really really bothered
me and it's still bothering me now like
what i'm thinking about but yeah it's so
i'm just telling you the dog gets it so
okay
telling you that ahead of time now at
this point uh after particularly after
the dog gets killed and after he beats
up on the neighborhood kid
andy's dad charles uh is very very
certain this his son is not really his
son anymore
and he's kind of starts to have a crisis
over whether he should turn andy into
the police after he ends up finding out
about the truck driver they don't know
for sure that he killed the truck driver
but you know they're like oh he arrived
in town at the same time and it's just
kind of like there was a lot of like
circumstantial evidence and so they're
just kind of like it was probably him uh
you know what i mean and then later on
the town doctor who too who was a friend
of the family and said he was gonna
check out andy to like see what was
wrong with him like he turns up dead too
so
you know andy's dad is pretty much like
yeah i think my son is like not only a
dog killer but he's actually like a
person killer too so maybe i should go
to the cops and then he can't decide
he's like he's still my son and he
doesn't really know what to do and then
like he starts drinking and like i said
he starts having screaming matches with
his wife and it's like threatening to
kick andy out of the house if he doesn't
like straighten up and all this other
kind of [ __ ] and it's like i said it's
just a really really bad situation like
the family situation like really starts
to deteriorate and you know christine
even as bad as it gets even after you
know uh even after charles tells her
you know i'm pretty sure he killed
somebody at least one person she's just
like no you know it's not him it's not
him it was a mistake and she's like she
doesn't want to hear it which like i
said it's understandable but you can
also understand like why the husband is
like super mad because it's like
obviously he's the boy's not right so
the long and short of the story is that
andy is actually some kind of
vampire zombie revenant some type of
thing uh the exact mechanics of his
return are thankfully uh left ambiguous
but what is clear just very similar to
the story the monkeys paw that this was
inspired by even though that actually
had like a magic you know thing from you
know the orient or whatever the [ __ ] it
was like you know that you wished on uh
this is like that but it doesn't have
it doesn't have that it doesn't have the
mcguffin or whatever of the monkey's paw
it's basically just you're led to
believe that it was some kind of dark
magic that was maybe like set in motion
by
just the strength of his mother's hopes
that he didn't get killed in the war and
her
doing these weird like incantations
maybe something heard her and said okay
well careful what you wish for babe here
it is and so it manifested itself into
reality somehow
so like a zombie andy kind of slowly
begins to decay over the course of the
story
but like a vampire he seems to restore
himself temporarily by drinking the
blood of the people that he kills and he
doesn't i don't think he drinks it out
of their neck like by he does tear their
throats out but i think that he kind of
like takes it out with syringe or
something like that and like drinks just
kind of like martin now that i'm
thinking about it but yeah so but it
does seem to it it seems to like restore
him for a bit but then like it's kind of
like holding off because he's decaying
he's dead i mean you know he's a dead
person like a zombie so i mean the
parameters of what andy actually is
aren't really important though like for
the movie yes this is technically a sort
of living dead monster kind of movie but
andy's supernatural affliction or
whatever it is
is also just kind of like a metaphorical
device which is sort of exploring how
people who have witnessed the death and
devastation of war might come back from
the experience irreparably damaged now
like i said you don't have to read it
like that because this is very much like
a straight ahead just creepy horror
movie uh much in the vein of the
monkey's paw like i said but it's pretty
clear that that's what the metaphor is
like he's come back for more he's seen a
bunch of horrible [ __ ] and he's not the
same and in this case like it that takes
that to an extreme you know what i'm
saying
now i mean so if you're into creepy sort
of slow burn 1970s horror stuff like
maybe like let's scare jessica to death
or alice sweet alice or something like
that um this is kind of the same like
tonally the same as those so if you
haven't seen it you should definitely
give this one a watch i think it's
really underappreciated it had like
really really good acting in it really
good special effects like i said tom
savini worked on it when he was still
real young had a very very haunting like
kind of heartbreaking ending and had
some really really effective sequences
that were actually like really unnerving
like the way it was shot was like kind
of unnerving also recommended of course
if you're into bob clark's other movies
like black christmas or children
shouldn't play with dead things or you
know or alan ormsby's other work as well
and if you haven't seen it you should
definitely check it out at the moment it
is on uh 2b and it's probably blake for
free and i'm sure it's probably on other
streaming services as well so if you
haven't seen it you're into 70s horror
then definitely check it out because
it's really really good so that will do
it for this flickers of fear and i will
see you guys on the next one bye